we have this poll from kipc this one's
got people all hot and bothered 2024
presidential race stays static in the
face of major events kipc University
National poll finds RFK Jr receives 22%
as independent candidate in three-way
race now the interesting thing here is
that with the independent candidate they
say that Joe wins they say uh uh well
let me just pull up the actual
Quinnipiac here from 538 they say
actually it looks like if they include
Cornell West but Joe Biden gets
39% Trump gets 36 and Kennedy gets 22
now a lot of people are responding
especially Trump supporters being like
what's 22% who that are you polling now
quinc also has this poll including
Cornell West I love it if Cornell West
runs apparently Trump still loses okay
wait hold on a minute I I'm I'm like
it's really funny when they put both of
these Mets out at the same time okay so
it's Biden Trump Kennedy on the ticket
Kennedy gets 22% but if you add Cornell
West someone pulls one point away from
Donald Trump are they implying Cornell
West will take 1% of Trump's voters
Cornell West he's he's super far left
right I mean I just that's ridiculous
he's he's recording the same demographic
As Trump 100% sure I that's just it's a
ridiculous idea that Trump would lose
because of West and Kennedy and when you
look at all the other polls take a look
at this one Redfield Wilton strategies
Kennedy 10% Trump wins 40 to 38 they
have another poll showing it's 35 to 33
with Kennedy at 10% probably because
they might have Cornell West in there
you have this one from mclin Biden 35
Trump 38 Kennedy 12 West two mofin also
has Trump winning all the other polls at
least Abacus has a tie so there's one
poll showing Trump losing I guess
technically say quak has two and then
Abacus showing a tie and the other polls
we've got uh one two I believe three
four uh four other polls showing Trump
wins with Kennedy on the uh on the
ballot I I don't know for sure but I'm
I'm definitely leaning towards I do not
see Trump voters leaving I'm talking
about I'm talking about Maga I'm talking
about moderate independent types I don't
see them being like I'll vote for
Kennedy instead of trump some May but
it's mostly going to be Democrats who
think Biden can't win and that Biden is
horrible he's corrupt he's a warmonger
and they're going to vote for for for
Kenedy I agree I think I think Biden's
doing all the work for him you know all
the work for these other candidates
right now in my district in Ohio it's
it's highly independent and you know I I
see a huge swing for um voters driving
towards Trump just because of what he's
standing for and and the fact that he's
getting attacked so terribly they're
they're seeing the reality of politics
right now a Biden speech from I guess
four years ago and man he sounded clear
like a normal guy and now when you
listen to him it is freak it she is just
tired it's exponential you know it's
like the the decline accelerates the
older you get so it's a curve straight
straight down I'm so concerned I'm torn
because I'd like to meet him and help
his help his brain a little bit because
he is our commander you can't help his
brain e just listen to him like let him
kind of wake himself up a little bit
well and it's degenerative right that's
the sad thing about dementia illnesses
right like any kind of elderly
atrophying it it's not reversible it's
not coming back you can't I've seen THC
consume amalo plaque which is the cause
of Alzheimer's in a in a microscope I'd
have to continue to look for more data
to back that up but I think believe I've
seen that also I hear psilocybin helps
people an older age there might be in
the future but right now we have very
little if any way at all to slow or stop
these Progressive degenerative diseases
and I think that's St cells right to the
brain yeah I mean maybe there's
something and maybe if we're testing
them you know experimental treatments
you know giving us an option in the VA
maybe you know Biden can get have a
chance to try this out but realistically
in the next year he is not going to
suddenly imp improve considering we've
seen a consistent decline on last so if
he walked into a chamber and it would
closed like and he came out and he
looked like 38 would you vote for him no
if he was healthy like a 30y old he's a
Democrat I mean I he's still evil he
look 38 he's young evil he he would look
38 and I still need him to close the
border which he won't he was get all
that Biden money back though from the
the Gap you yeah what's this what's the
story now they they $40,000 in in
launder payments oh what's that yeah
yeah there's like uh so there was a
$200,000 payment from his brother now
apparently there's a report about
$40,000 paid directly to Joe Biden which
appears to be laundered from China man
I'm glad you brought up the Border it's
just I I probably you guys talk about it
a lot I hope hopefully it gets talked
about a lot and are they building it up
right now because it's like yo if we're
really going to about to spark a war in
the Middle East or like jump into the
fire over there we better have closed
borders yeah I mean at this point sense
if if if you were in a dangerous
neighborhood I've said this a hundred
times on the show but if you were in a
dangerous neighborhood you would lock
your own front door and instead we're
like no it's fine let's open all of the
windows let's just pretend like
everything is cool but it's not just
that if you're going to throw a flaming
bag of feces at your neighbor's house
you're going to also lock your doors
because your neighbor is going to get
mad at you now I'm that I guess I could
technically say the US is basically
doing this because we shouldn't be
involved in this stuff anyway but the US
getting involved in all of these
conflicts and leaving the back door
open yeah and the front door with Canada
like I know there are allies but that
doesn't mean Canadian or that doesn't
mean like Chinese tanks can't just roll
through central Canada into like there's
no barrier dude no there was a there was
a story about a bunch of like
20-year-olds and they just drove down
the border and then just turned into the
United States mhm I think they got got
in trouble the Pacific Northwest yeah
cuz there's no barriers there no you
know there's just like it's like the
trees are cut and they have drones
Patrol sometimes you go to the southern
border and it's like some some areas you
know there's nothing but there's a lot
of Ballard fencing and then there's
patrols that go up and down and you've
got the militias down there yeah didn't
we have the Chinese military was caught
practicing some drill or performing
military drills in Canada last year if
I'm not mistaken I don't think they were
caught I think that was like a joint
effort between Canada and China man yeah
seems like the Chinese don't want any
military conflict with the US they had
Gavin Newsome over there to talk to shei
president I was going to call him
Emperor shei president shei uh but you
know and they were like we're going to
do anything we can to preserve peace
between us but that I wouldn't put a
past him to say that and then declare an
invasion that's like stuff Hitler would
have done I saw a video of a guy in
China eating at I think it was a Pizza
Hut and they can stuff the crust with
hot dogs and when I saw that I was just
like we're doomed you know you know and
I'm and I'm I would I wouldn't say half
I would say that's that's 75% a joke the
reality is they are uh uh competing with
us in in a lot of ways that we should be
the best at and I don't literally mean
putting hot dogs in Pizza it's just that
we're giving up our manufacturing only
now in the past several years seem to
have realized that we've given up the in
industry and Manufacturing we need to
maintain an economy and now you're
seeing China's they're they're cranking
away they're burning coal baby just
smogging it up and by the way I'm going
to interview James T at Rice
University's leading graphine scientist
on Earth uh and he they're working on
flash Jewel uh graphine where they hit
carbon trash with lasers and can produce
this black powder this stuff this is the
21st century building material that
we'll need to revolutionize our country
with I don't know though one of them
probably maybe it's just like the
graphine story came out 20 years ago it
was like graphine the Wonder material 20
years ago and so we got some cool stuff
from it but you know I wonder I think
it's really going to come down to the
basics are we producing Steel
right are we are are we well I think you
can use you can put this stuff in with
like carbonized steel if you're going to
make it and make it stronger and lighter
and also with um with car with coal like
you were saying we burn coal you can
upscale coal into graphine and burn it
cleaner so there are some I'm I'm very
excited it's going to be uh Friday
afternoon so keep in touch on my Twitter
and you can watch it there so there
let's reindustrialize go for it what you
say oh I was going to say I mean I I I
want to believe in science and
Innovation I really do but I get sort of
uh frustrated with it when ultimately
you know if if graphine is the future
maybe it does I don't I know nothing
about it but is America going to do
something about it or is it going to be
China right like what country is
actually most likely to be ahead in
terms of manufacturing these things and
I would assume it's the country where we
put all of the manufacturing and so in
some ways we've an we've we've uh
hamstring our own ability to embrace
Innovation by shipping all of these
things overseas I mean even if someone
in a lab at a university in America
comes up with something ultimately the
technology is getting shipped out of the
country to develop in my cynical opinion
I would counter that uh those would
become obsolete factories over there now
we'll start building new ones that focus
on flash Jewel creation if we build them
here I'm okay with it I just don't know
that we will well that's what we're
trying to do in Arizona and places like
that where we could actually have these
factories so if that actually happens
and a lot of like the reasons for taking
Taiwan or protecting Taiwan become
secondary to us actually having the
factories back in the United States
that's not all manufacturing though like
China can out manufactur us with like
raw product but when it comes to like
technical manufacturing yeah that's
going to be huge in the next 20 years
biggest place we're handicapped in
comparison with China is in in
regulatory framework I mean if you look
at you know how our government hyper
regulates not only the uh the the
industrial side of manufacturing but
then the energy side right and I mean
that's you know my my kind of my
wheelhouse right and that's why we have
you know the the stifling of small
modular reactors and you know we have
companies that American innovators that
are having to take their technology to
Canada and go through the regulatory
board there hoping that the NRC here the
nuclear Regulatory Commission here will
finally open up the gates and allow them
to uh build smrs here and we we're
losing out on
on in every small modular reactor how
does that work um it's essentially you
know it's it's a mini reactor that is
you know mechanically incapable mod reor
of melting down you can you can power a
small city with a reactor the size of
this room need no operators I and it
can't melt down right cannot melt down
what what kind of what's the fuel source
um still uranium but it's it's it's um
too small passive technology I mean it
it it it doesn't rely on operators the
the the way it's designed I'm no I'm no
physicist or or nuclear engineer but um
you know the the way I understand it is
um the recirculation system the cooling
system they're all you know they're all
passive and reliant on condensation and
and the the systems working in with one
another so there's no oper operator
manipulation what about Thorium salt
we've heard a lot about that um I think
thorium Salt's another awesome
opportunity for us that we're just I
mean there's there's there there's
reactors out there that I mean there's
there's ways to convert our retired coal
plants in thorium salt reactors yeah
there's American I used to work for a
guy that invented that um name is doct
Singh and he introduced it to our
federal government Department of energy
they don't they like why why aren't we
doing these why why are we not doing it
because the money is not going in the
right pocket it's because of Greta
tunberg isn't it that son of she's
hungry for the cash Greta in your
experience how has American how's the
American public's opinion shifted on
nuclear because I feel like that's
ultimately if there were people calling
for it eventually someone would do it
right I mean they're doing it the the
problem is I mean there is a there is a
um a specific Paradigm around nuclear
power people drive by cooling towers and
they think that's the reactor and a lot
of it has to do with the nuclear power
plants not having to Market over the
years they've been in they've been in um
you know regulated environments where
they know they're going to charge a
certain amount per megawatt you know and
and and they're going to get paid
because people have to turn their lights
on but then when you have different
forms of energy that are subsidized by
the federal government that undercut the
market then nuclear becomes well I blame
the cens yeah but for real the so this
is actually true Simpsons is considered
to be a factor maybe not the biggest in
why there is resistance to nuclear
energy because people grew up watching
this joke of Springfield of mutated fish
three-eyed fish three-eyed fish Blinky
and meltdowns I think are a theme of a
dozen episodes at least and so people
are consuming media and they're
believing these things are based on
reality they say well every joke has its
truth and it's like no like there's not
going to be a nuclear plant so close to
you like this it's not going to blow up
you're not going to die there are less
deaths from nuclear power than from coal
and like it's it's exponential the
nuclear power industry is the safest
industry one of the safest Industries in
the country yeah absolutely what's the
biggest misconception about radiation
damage like what I think what happened
is uh when Sher Noble melted down it
just what what all the the spent nuclear
corium or whatever was just there so it
was constantly irradiating the
environment bur it into the air and then
you had the Meltdown which created the
elephant's foot and then had they been
able to extract the corium then would it
have no longer been irradiating and it'
go back to normal I mean if you remove
the source yeah then you would have no
no radiation the problem with Chernobyl
is that when it exploded it sprayed
radioactive uh uh particulates
everywhere which blanketed down over the
region and when when the West was like
Hey Russia what's going on there like
nothing's happening everything's fine
and they're like uh now we're getting
slammed by radiation radio like
radioactive particles so we know
something happened I was thinking about
corium meltdowns corium is like the
stuff in the middle that when it gets
really hot goes and it goes through
cement and it'll just keep melting down
if you pour gold into it that it will
create act as a superc conductor and
allow the corium to cool itself off and
release the Heat so it'll it then it'll
Harden and then you could extract it I'm
not sure that uh gamma rays wouldn't
pass through that I mean if if it could
be x-rayed then you can still have you
know a fision product I would assume I
mean the only real shielding mechanism
that you're going to have from um
radiation of that source is going to be
water or lead or high density concrete
it wouldn't be to Shield it would just
be more to extract it so you could so it
gets out of its liquid form even then
you have to worry about the dose
exposure that you're going to get as a
human you can only get so much before
you're internal organs are going to be
you have to send a robot in to do it I
think the biggest misconception based on
my personal experience is that you're
dealing with GMA wave radiation instead
of Alpha and beta particles right so
this is what I learned when I went to
Fukushima they give me these they give
you this cloth suit to put on and I was
like is a joke and they're like this is
what you have to wear why you they're
not worried about you getting bombarded
by waves that go through everything
they're worried about the particles
landing on your skin which are
radioactive and then you eating them or
getting them in your lungs so that's
internal source yeah so so what what
you're you wear these these cloth suits
and then when you're when you're leaving
you take them off very carefully they B
Bunch them up and throw them the garbage
we mentioned thorium salt earlier can
you really quickly generally explain
what that is a thorium salt reactor oh
that's kind of out of my wheelhouse but
I know that you know the thorium salt is
essentially heated up probably through
the through the uh super steam process
and then that kind of creates uh a like
a resonating heat source which then
continues to create the super Steam
which turns the turbine right so isn't
that really funny that's all it is yeah
we we like we we pressurize a tube so
that it pushes steam which spins it's
kind of simple like I sort of like that
you know one other question it's a big
magnet spin creat an oal current that's
there you go so my other question on
nuclear is what about fusion and I know
these get conflated because they're not
even remotely the same process but
they're both called nuclear power which
is kind of weird maybe so but what do
you think about Fusion is that even
anything you've ever studied no I mean
you know in my opinion the future again
it goes back to the standard way of of
of of nuclear fion right just having
smaller more manageable less scary to
the public reactors things that you know
take out the human element because
that's really where you've seen these
meltdowns or you've seen these close
calls what the general public hasn't
been communicated to is like there was
always a safety actuation system that
stopped the general public from being
harmed there's you know what they call
defense in depth there's always like
three to four different layers of
defense you know with these nuclear
power plants at least in the United
States right Europe has totally
different standards but here in the US
you had Davis besti you had three m
Island I mean we were pretty far away
from actually having a miltown but you
know when it it's uh communicated to the
public it's all about you know scaring
them have you heard of those nuclear
Diamond batteries where they have like
spent nuclear Fuel and they put it
inside of like a diamond and it just
gives you a low pulse of energy can you
explain that real Qui I don't know I've
heard of them but I don't know much I
don't know much give you like 10,000
years of electricity what like a phone
um yeah things like that really really
low charge and then I guess you could
have a lot of them to create a greater
charge but it's actually nuclear waste
inside of a diamond inside of like
carbon that's what we're missing out on
is this recycling of SP nuclear fuel
when this nuclear fuel comes out of the
reactor it's only using 5 to 7% of its
energy potential and we have like
86,000 or you know kilogram or whatever
of metric tons of spent nuclear fuel you
know sitting in the United States that
we're not using and you have countries
like Europe that are reprocessing and
they're and they're reusing their spent
nuclear fuel we're throwing it in
canisters and leaving it at the uh
nuclear reactors across the country and
that's a multi-billion dollar industry
that we could be opening and creating
highp paying jobs high paying technical
jobs for a bunch of people we're not
doing it and people don't do it because
there's a fear of
nuclear maybe not after tonight we're
changing hearts and Minds over here not
too nuclear diamonds we just need to
bring back that guy from the Biden
Administration the like non-binary guy
who kept stealing luggage maybe he can
save the day thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 p.m. and become a member over at
timcast.net